seulement 500 habitants mais près de
15000 personnes attendues pour la fête
de la Rose hachez Dini on se prépare
pour les festivités avec au programme
exposition rencontre avec des artistes
concerts et surtout promenade dans des
rues colorées et parfumées certains
touristes n'ont d'ailleurs pas attendu
l'événement pour venir admirer plus de
1000 rosiers qui décorent le village
reportage d'Hélène chapelet
ce vendredi matin 24 heures avant le
lancement officiel de la 17e édition du
festival des roses le village de chez
Dini accueillait déjà de nombreux
visiteurs tous sont sous le charme du
lieu et des nombreuses fleurs qui ornent
les façades
on est venu avec des amis et puis ben
voilà là on va profiter des roses de
tout ce qu'il y a autour de toutes les
fleurs qu'il y a c'est tellement
magnifique et bien nous sommes venus
pour être un peu au calme profiter des
mouvements tranquilles dans les Russes
sans être bousculé on avait découvert à
l'Office de Tourisme ce joli village
très très fleuri et on a venu voulu
venir les voir ces roses qui parfume qui
ont baume tout le village et vous allez
rester demain pour la fête ou pas
certainement
15 à 20 000 personnes sont attendues
dans ce petit bourg de 500 âmes
désormais connu pour la beauté de son
fleurissement tout a commencé il y a
bientôt 25 ans avec les premières
plantations dans l'espace public
aujourd'hui mille à 1200 rosiers ornent
les rues en plus des 3000 vivaces
je connais chez lui depuis tout petit et
je suis très heureux de voir comment ça
évolué je suis très heureux de voir que
les gens viennent nous voir parce que
c'est joli parce qu'il y a des fleurs
parce que c'est c'est très agréable à
vivre on nous dit surtout vous avez de
la chance de vivre ici et moi je dis
tout le temps la chance on l'a provoqué
toutes ces plantations sont entretenues
à l'année par les trois jardiniers
permanents de la commune chez Dini un
village jardin qui refuse la grisaille
du béton un lieu à découvrir ce week-end
pour y rencontrer de nombreux rosiers
riches et pépiniéristes où tout le reste
de l'année pour profiter de sa quiétude
reposante